[Applaudissements]
gagner en politique fait vivre
l'exaltation
l'espoir de laisser sa trace de marquer
l'histoire mais après avoir goûté à
l'émotion forte de la victoire la
défaite est vertigineuse
à nous rencontrer
plusieurs anciens élus se sentent trop
fragiles encore pour se confier
publiquement dépression idées noires
séparation ils sont bien plus nombreux
qu'on pense atterrés par leurs défaites
Gaudreault se sont soutenus l'un et
l'autre après avoir perdu leur comté en
Outaouais marque a passé 10 ans
l'Assemblée nationale maryse en Afrique
le député de Chapelot monsieur Marc
carrière élu dans un château fort
libéral lui n'a pas du tout vu venir le
revers en 2018 convaincu d'avoir livré
la marchandise pour ses citoyens moi je
l'appelais j'écrivais
[Musique]
moi je l'ai pris un peu personnel
assez pour devoir se couper de la
réalité
moi j'ai vraiment
coupé pas mal tout contact à l'époque
au point de s'isoler pendant quelques
semaines
totalement un jour parmi les doyennes de
l'Assemblée nationale Maryse a connu le
même sort aux dernières élections le
lendemain matin j'aime bien en être avec
vous j'ai tellement pleuré l'Assemblée
nationale lui donnait 10 jours pour
vider son bureau de comté on parle
beaucoup des conditions de travail des
élus quand ils sont élus mais je pense
qu'on devrait parler aussi des
conditions
humaines de quelqu'un qui a passé 15 ans
de sa vie au Parlement puis du jour au
lendemain il est plus dans le portrait
la transition est aussi douloureuse pour
les élus fédéraux on veut parler un peu
de la vie après la politique le leader
du gouvernement en chambre marque
Hollande a touché le fond du Barry après
sa défaite en 2011
[Musique]
il a révélé publiquement avoir fait une
tentative de suicide c'est tellement
difficile de trouver une raison de vivre
oui absolument parce que c'est vraiment
une passion c'était mon rêve qu'on quand
j'étais jeune maintenant qu'il est
revenu
on peut tout misé sur la politique au
détriment de la vie personnelle pour que
la défaite fasse moins mal il milite
aussi pour que les élus obtiennent un
meilleur soutien de leur institution
généralement je pense qu'une autre
système manque comme passion au
printemps dernier un comité d'ex
parlementaire de Québec c'est penché sur
la question la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale affirme que des agents de
liaison font la promotion d'un programme
de soutien il prévoit entre autres une
somme pouvant aller jusqu'à 1700 dollars
pour que l'ex parlementaire puisse aller
chercher de l'aide et quand je parle de
l'aide c'est varié de l'aide
psychologique des psychologues des
thérapeutes si le besoin sera fait
ressentir même aussi des orienteurs tous
les députés qui se sont confiés à nous
ne connaissent pourtant pas l'existence
du programme en effectuant une recherche
ailleurs dans le monde ça ne semble pas
mieux dans les autres législatures soit
que le sujet est à bout ou alors
personne ne s'est encore vraiment penché
là-dessus
ma carrière a beaucoup hésité avant de
se relancer dans une course pour devenir
préfet de sa MRC puis le fait de gagner
est-ce que ça vous a comme réconcilier
avec la politique
elle fait son deuil de la politique même
si elle n'a pas totalement décroché je
suis encore très branché sur la période
de questions sur l'actualité vous avez
pas fait de couper pas du tout et j'en
ferai pas non pour moi la politique
active ça fait partie de ma vie depuis
plus de 22 ans ça c'est moi ça fait
partie de moi et la victoire comme la
défaite ça fait partie de la politique
mais rendre tout ça plus humain devient
nécessaire selon eux pour recruter les
meilleures candidats ici Véronique
prince Radio-Canada Québec